Show 109% by shading.
So just as a bit of review, 109%
if we were to write it
out, would literally be 109
percent, which is the same
thing as 109 per-- and I could
write cent again, but that's
getting old.
Cent means 100, so it literally
means 109 per hundred.
If you had 100 per 100, you're
dealing with the whole, but
now we have more than a whole.
We have 109 per 100.
We can actually write this as
a ratio, or as a fraction.
This is the same thing
as 109 per 100.
It's the the same thing
as 109/100.
So let's shade that in.
So we have a whole here,
so we could consider
this square a whole.
In the last video, we counted.
This is a 10 by 10 square.
It is cut up into 100 pieces.
So if we want 109 of those
100 pieces, what
are we talking about?
That means we're going to
shade in all of the
100 right over here.
Let me do that in a new color.
So we'll shade in all of this.
If you just shaded that in,
that would be 100%.
That would be 100/100, or
100 per 100, or 100%.
I think you're getting the
meaning of all of this.
I don't just want you just
memorize this stuff.
This really just means 100
out of 100, or a whole.
And you can see that this
is the whole square.
That's 100 out of
100 right there.
The question is saying show
us 109% by shading.
We already did 100 per 100, but
we need to do another 9,
so let's shade in another 9.
So now we have one, two, three,
four, five, six, seven,
eight, nine.
So this piece right here, you
could almost view that is--
well, that is!
That is 9% of an
entire square.
This is 100% of an
If you considered this whole
thing plus this blue area
right over here, you are talking
about 109% of one
whole square.
Hopefully, that made sense.